milliardenhilfen gegen die krise
familien mieter beschäftigte unternehmen
sie will die regierung im
schnellverfahren unterstützen und nimmt
die mense schulden in kauf
bitte abstand halten überall in
deutschland überprüft die polizei die
neuen kontakt beschränkungen zum schutz
vor ansteckung olympia erst nächstes
jahr sportler länder und verbände
fordern wegen corona eine verschiebung
der spiele
nachrichten licht des heute mit
christian sievers einen guten abend
hinein an diesem montag danke dass sie
dabei sind das schon mal vorweg wir
haben in den kommenden zwanzig minuten
den überblick über den nachrichten tag
für sie und er beginnt mit einem
beispiellosen hilfspaket das jetzt
allerdings auch bei denen ankommen muss
die es dringend brauchen
das bundeskabinett hat eine ganze reihe
von leistungen auf den weg gebracht und
dafür wird sich dieses land mit der
rekord summe von 150 milliarden euro neu
verschulden
schauen wir uns mal die details an
größere und mittlere firmen sollen über
kredite an geld kommen können und zwar
so heißt es in unbegrenzter höhe
kleinste unternehmen und selbstständige
können einen einmaligen zuschuss
beantragen von maximal 15.000 euro er
muss also nicht zurückgezahlt werden
dann die mieter innen darf nicht
gekündigt werden nur weil sie mit der
miete im rückstand sind
und wer hartz 4 beantragen muss für den
werden die bürokratischen hürden gesenkt
zum beispiel bei der vermögensprüfung
nicole diekmann berichtet
pressekonferenzen die später starten als
geplant diese an einem montag an dem das
kabinett getagt hatte statt wie sonst
immer mittwochs das politische berlin in
den zeiten von corolla umso lieber
verkündeten finanz und
wirtschaftsminister konkrete maßnahmen
etwa für die sogenannten rund zehn
millionen klein- und solo
selbstständigen wie musiker private
pflegedienste oder heilpraktiker
geschätzte unternehmen kleine
unternehmen mit bis zu fünf
beschäftigten einmalzahlungen leisten
von 9000 euro für drei monate insgesamt
die unternehmen bis zu zehn
beschäftigten werden wir 15.000 euro
einmalzahlung leisten ebenfalls für drei
monate
außerdem wer im zeitraum vom ersten
april bis zum 30 september seine miete
nicht zahlen kann soll nicht gekündigt
werden dürfen sofern das virus der grund
ist der nachweis dafür soll
unkompliziert er bringt sein und
kurzarbeitergeld 60 prozent des lohns
übernimmt die bundesagentur für arbeit
bei familien mit kindern 67
es steht unternehmen zu bei denen
mindestens zehn prozent der
beschäftigten davon betroffen sind die
unternehmen haben nachdem sie so sehr
von uns entlastet worden sind eigentlich
die sozialpartnerschaftliche
verpflichtung eine aufstockung zu
ermöglichen wenn sie dazu die
finanzkraft haben aus der opposition
kritik allerdings vorsichtiger was wir
natürlich beachten muss ist angesichts
der größe der maßnahmen wie schaut's aus
einem tilgungsplan die hilfen die jetzt
in aussicht gestellt worden sind sind
noch nicht überall so geländegängig dass
sie in der praxis angekommen wären es
ist ein dickes paket insgesamt rund 750
milliarden darin auch eine finanzspritze
für krankenhäuser
ob diese dosis ausreicht das mag heute
wohl noch niemand beantworten ja so
einen nachtragshaushalt hat es in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik noch nie
gegeben
guten abend das sind summen bei denen
einem schwindlig werden kann damit ist
die schwarze null schon mal dahin kann
sich deutschland so etwas leisten
ich befürchte man muss die gegenfrage
stellen kann man es sich leisten ist
nicht zu machen denn die folgen der
krise dürften ja eh dramatisch genug
werden gemindert
jedes kurzarbeitergeld jeder
überbrückungskredit die erste wucht der
pleiten und entlassungen
die bundesrepublik steht ja nach sechs
jahren ohne neue schulden relativ gut da
und die eu gewährt jetzt zusätzliche
spielräume bei der schuldengrenze wenn
wir uns umgerechnet pro kopf erhöht
dieser nachtragshaushalt die
schuldenlast in deutschland um knapp
2000 euro
aber der langfrist schaden oder das
hilfspaket glaube ich könnte noch viel
größer sein
und dann gucken wir mal auf das ganz
praktische wie konkret sind denn die
vorbereitungen dass das jetzt auch
tatsächlich schnell und wie es immer so
schön heißt unbürokratisch läuft es wird
auf jeden fall ein kraft der aktion das
dürfte glaube ich mehr probleme geben
als den betroffenen lieb ist nur zwei
beispiele zu nennen werden
kurzarbeitergeld müssen die
arbeitsagenturen ja jetzt eine flut von
anträgen bearbeiten und selbst wenn wir
dort schnell und unbürokratisch helfen
will es entsteht auf jeden fall einen
flaschenhals allein schon durch die
schiere masse und bei den
überbrückungskrediten hat der
finanzminister zwar gesagt dass
die kfw innerhalb von ein zwei tagen
über die staatliche 90 prozent garantie
entscheiden soll aber führende
wirtschaftsvertreter hier befürchten
dass die geschäftsbanken dann trotzdem
nicht in jedem fall die haftung für die
restliche summe übernehmen werden also
das hilfspaket ist groß und geschnürt
aber sofort an den inhalt zu kommen
dürfte nicht ganz so leicht sein
theo herzlichen dank für diese
erläuterung und auch das ist ohne
beispiel das tägliche leben hat sich für
uns alle enorm verändert es gilt eine
weitgehende kontaktsperre viele
geschäfte mussten schließen
wie das ergebnis aussieht heute in
deutschland zeigt oliver decker hannover
innenstadt wenige menschen sind
unterwegs
der beschluss der länder und des bundes
zeigt ihr wirkung demnach ist nur noch
der aufenthalt in der öffentlichkeit mit
einer weiteren person erlaubt als
ausnahme gelten familienangehörige oder
in einem haushalt zusammen lebende die
polizei hat die kontrollen dazu
verstärkt zeigt präsenz zunächst einmal
erfolgt eine ansprache das heißt auch
häufig mal über lautsprecher oder eben
mit der entsprechenden distanz auch wir
halten uns ja soweit es irgend geht an
die regeln und die meisten menschen
reagieren dann auch schon entsprechend
es gibt natürlich auch einzelfälle wo
die menschen nicht zu reagieren
und dann gibt es auch entsprechende
maßnahmen so wurden in hannover schon
einige bußgelder verhängt münchen nicht
ausgestorben die city aber auch hier
sind deutlich weniger menschen auf der
straße und wenn halten sie abstand
voneinander die ausgangs beschränkung
wird größtenteils eingehalten und
akzeptiert für mich nachvollziehbar als
wir als bürger und ich denke weiter so
ich fühle mich ganz gut
fazit oder vor der regierung betreut
also ich finde auch ganz gut dass es
eine ausgangs begrenzung ist im moment
keine sperre in mannheim sind die
maßnahmen allerdings scharfe am morgen
sperrte die stadt per allgemeinverfügung
einige öffentliche plätze
es kommt jetzt ganz entscheidend darauf
an wie die einzelnen bundesländer und co
die vereinbarten leitlinien umsetzen
werden denn ausgangs verbote kontakt
beschränkung können nur länder und
kommunen anordnen klar ist aber jetzt
schon dass sie sich stark an den
leitlinien orientieren so dass wir am
ende ganz praktisch in deutschland fast
einheitliche regelungen haben mit ganz
kleinen abweichungen tag eins der
ausgang zu beschränkungen in deutschland
das öffentliche leben ist bundesweit
stark zurückgegangen eine gute chance
die ausbreitung des virus einzudämmen
und da gehen wir jetzt live ins
normalerweise quirlige zentrum von
berlin auf den alexanderplatz dort des
carsten behrendt rund kasten wie ist die
situation heute abend ja gerade fährt
wieder hinter mir eine fast
menschenleere straßen bahnen durchs bild
nicht mehr als ein dutzend leute sitzen
da in der regel drin es ist hier auf dem
alex leer wie an vielen anderen orten
der stadt auch ich bin die ganze zeit
mit dem handy unterwegs filme hier von
einem surfstick ohne kamera team
deswegen kann ich mich auch etwas anders
bewegen und für mich symbolisch ist
eigentlich hier die weltzeituhr die
jetzt hinter mir ist weil die für ein
recht ambivalentes bild steht was ich
heute in berlin gewonnen habe nach außen
da läuft die uhr ticken die uhren hier
in berlin viel langsamer also ist es
weniger berufsverkehr da alles ist
geschlossen alles wirkt so ruhig und
innen drin wenn ich mit menschen mich
unterhalte mit gehörigem
sicherheitsabstand natürlich dann merke
ich dass ein unheimlicher stress ist
dass die innere uhr im turbo modus läuft
zum einen weil manche eben in
systemrelevanten berufen jetzt unter
diesen bedingungen arbeiten müssen
zum anderen aber auch weil viele
familien jetzt in einem spagat sind
zwischen home office und homeschooling
also zu hause die kinder noch
unterrichten müssen das verlangt vielen
eine menge ab und dieser stresstest der
iss verbunden mit der forderung an die
politik dass diese maßnahmen die jetzt
eingeleitet worden sind wirklich ständig
und immer wieder mit dem warum wie lange
und
schaffen wir damit wirklich den kämpfen
des virus verbunden sind ja dafür stehen
dann alle für dieses alle für alle und
sind daneben auch bereit das zu machen
aber im verbunden mit großem
persönlichen belastungen das bild in
deutschland heute abend kasten
herzlichen dank nach berlin
und jetzt kommt der moment in dieser
sendung an den wir auf die
infektionszahlen gucken müssen in
deutschland das ist ja die statistik auf
die ein ganzes land jetzt gebannt schaut
anselm stern hat den aktuellen stand das
virus weiter auf dem vormarsch
aktuell gibt es in deutschland 28 1784
bestätigte infektionen 116 menschen sind
gestorben
das meldet die johns hopkins universität
stand 18 uhr 30 die forscher aus
baltimore haben die aktuellsten zahlen
sie nutzen mehrere quellen die
weltgesundheitsorganisation etwa aber
auch die vielen verschiedenen
gesundheitsämter und sie durchsuchen das
netz twitter accounts von lokalen
behörden zum beispiel oder die
nachrichten von regionalen medien die
experten am robert-koch-institut haben
ganz andere zahlen sie bekommen neue
infektionen ausschließlich von den
gesundheitsämtern aus den bundesländern
übermittelt laut lka gibt es in
deutschland derzeit 22 1672 bestätigte
fälle
und 86 tote hier fehlen noch einige
zahlen vom wochenende
und doch hat deutschlands wichtigster
virologe heute auch diese botschaft wenn
alle mithelfen dann kann es hoffnung
geben
wir sehen den trend dass die
exponentielle wachstumskurve sich etwas
abflacht ich kann ihnen aber sagen dass
ich diesen trend wahrscheinlich am
mittwoch also übermorgen definitiv
bewerten kann aber ich bin optimistisch
dass diese maßnahmen schon jetzt
sichtbar sind was sehr früh ist will sie
erst seit einer woche wirklich gefahren
werden
zu hause bleiben abstand halten weiter
das gebot der stunde sagte experte nur
so habe man eine chance im kampf gegen
das virus
und das sind die neuesten zahlen aus
italien etwa 600 neue corona tote heute
aber den zweiten tag in folge hat sich
der anstieg etwas verlangsamt insgesamt
zählen die behörden fast 6000 80 tote so
viele wie in keinem anderen land der
welt
dramatisch ist die lage auch in spanien
33.000 infizierte und schon mehr als
2200 toten ärzte und pfleger arbeiten am
limit wie christel haas jetzt berichtet
ein messezentrum in madrid wird zum
krankenhaus in rekordzeit werden betten
aufgestellt neben jedem eine
sauerstoffflasche 5500 corona patienten
können hier versorgt werden wenn alles
fertig ist die ersten sind jetzt schon
eingetroffen
der abstand zwischen den becken ist sehr
groß wenn bedarf ist können wir statt 50
80 patienten pro station aufnehmen
madrid ist besonders schwer betroffen
von corona diese aufnahmen sollen aus
einem krankenhaus der stadt stammen die
patienten liegen oder sitzen auf dem
gang
dazwischen die pfleger die versuchen
allen zu helfen
zwölf prozent des personals landesweit
sind bereits selbst infiziert und die
todesfälle steigen weiter 2182 sind es
jetzt die regierung will deshalb den
alarmzustand verlängern
wir werden weitere zwei wochen brauchen
ich weiß das wird schwierig doch alle
müssen verantwortung zeigen
denn verantwortungslosigkeit kostet
menschen zdf-reporterin brigitte müller
erlebt jeden tag die angst die die
spanne um trägt die menschen sorgen sich
ob die krankenhäuser dem ihres gewachsen
sind
ärzte und pfleger sind die helden dieser
krise sie sind am ende ihrer kräfte
die regierung hat deshalb 53.000
funktionierte und angehende mediziner
mobilisiert und zu helfen
in cordoba gibt es mittlerweile eine
erste labor station die die bürger im
auto auf corona testet und dann sind da
noch die ärzte und pfleger zweier
krankenhäuser die sich gegenseitig
respekt zollen und allen danken die sich
ihrem kampf angeschlossen haben
und dann gucken wir die usa dort tobt
eine heftige diskussion um versäumnisse
der regierung und des präsidenten in der
korona krise mittlerweile wird auch dort
umfassender und besser getestet und in
der letzten woche hat sich die zahl der
offiziell als infiziert gemeldeten
menschen verneunfacht damit sind die usa
das land mit den drittmeisten fällen
weltweit mittlerweile 41 1026 besonders
betroffen new york city in der
millionenmetropole haben sich zwölf 1305
menschen infiziert die stadt sei das
epizentrum der korona pandemie in den
usa sagt der bürgermeister und warnt mit
drastischen worten johannes hano
berichtet new york heute morgen zur
rushhour wo sich sonst hunderttausende
dicht gedrängt auf fähren bussen u
bahnen oder in pendlerzügen drängen oder
sich auf den straßen durch endlose staus
zur arbeit wälzen fast gespenstische
leere
seit sonntagabend 20 uhr gilt eine
beschränkte ausgangssperre
es ist der verzweifelte versuch die
drohende katastrophe noch abzuwenden
in den früh- sendungen macht new yorks
bürgermeister mit dramatischen worten
klar worum es geht
es entwickelt sich so schnell ich kann
das nicht oft genug sagen unsere
öffentlichen krankenhäusern behandeln
die schwersten fälle mit den geringsten
ressourcen wenn wir keine
beatmungsgeräte bekommen werden ab ende
der woche menschen sterben die wir
hätten retten können
ich muss das so drastisch sagen
die positiv getesteten fälle steigen
dramatisch 99 menschen sind in der stadt
bislang an den folgen der krankheit
gestorben und die zahlen steigen mit
hoher geschwindigkeit es fehlt an allem
masken schutzausrüstung und
beatmungsgeräten new york ist zum
katastrophengebiet erklärt worden new
yorks gouverneur fordert von der
regierung in washington schon gestern
einen drastischen schritt eine
umstellung auf kriegswirtschaft die
federal government die regierung sollte
jetzt die medizinischen versorgungskette
vorübergehend verstaatlichen die
einzelnen bundesstaaten können das nicht
managen
dieser staat nicht und kein anderer mit
es ist ein hilferuf richtung washington
new york die größte stadt amerikas steht
schon in wenigen tagen vor dem
medizinischen kollaps jetzt rächt sich
dass der amerikanische präsident über
wochen das problem klein geredet hat
wichtige zeit zur vorbereitung ist
verloren gegangen
ein lichtblick die us
katastrophenschutzbehörde fema will hier
im new yorker messezentrum in den
nächsten tagen ein krankenhaus mit 1000
betten bauen
ein lichtblick aber auch viel schatten
wir gehen nach washington live zu elmar
theveßen
elmer ist dieser sinn dafür wie schlimm
es steht wir haben die bilder aus new
york gerade gesehen auch im rest des
landes angekommen
also ich glaube es kommt an bei den
menschen in den großstädten besonders in
den küsten metropolen weil sie ihm auch
die großen fallzahlen erleben und wissen
was es bedeutet aber in anderen
landesteilen ist das noch schwierig ein
beispiel in allen will im bundesstaat
new york im in einer ländlichen region
ist ein krankenhaus zuständig für circa
30.000 menschen dort hat man 24 betten
und ein beatmungsgerät und dazu kommt
dass gerade die ländliche bevölkerung in
den usa tendenziell eher älter ist also
anfälliger für das virus und obendrein
auch ärmer
das bedeutet dass in manchen landkreisen
die verantwortlichen sagen wir können
uns nicht erlauben hier einen
ausnahmezustand zu verhängen und die
menschen zu kontaktsperre zu bewegen
weil dann die wirtschaft komplett
zusammenbrechen würde die menschen
würden ihre existenz verlieren
also da ist so ein bisschen das prinzip
hoffnung dass dieses virus an ihnen
vorübergeht
dann sind wir auch noch wie vor immer
noch im präsidentschaftswahlkampf was
macht denn das virus mit der politik in
einem ohnehin schon gespaltenen land
also kann der kampf gegen korona einen
oder vertieft die gräben noch weiter
also momentan sind die gräben immer noch
sehr tief das liegt auch an einem
präsidenten der zwar öffentlich sagt
dass er so etwas wie ein präsident in
kriegszeiten ein wort ein präsident sein
will aber gleichzeitig eben gemischte
signale aussendet er könnte wie vorhin
schon mal im beitrag zu sehen die
kriegswirtschaft ausrufen das heißt er
könnte amerikanischen unternehmen
anordnen dass sie die wichtigsten dinge
die das land wort produzieren
beispielsweise schutzkleidung
beispielsweise auch diese atem
messgeräte die automobilindustrie hat
das nötige know how und die technologie
beispielsweise dafür aber stattdessen
erweckte immer noch den eindruck dass
mit wärmeren wetter möglicherweise dann
dieses virus verschwinden könnte letzte
nacht hat er getwittert dass man
aufpassen müsse dass nicht die maßnahmen
am ende größeren schaden anrichten als
eben das corona virus selber und
insinuiert dass er vielleicht in zwei
wochen einen teil dieser drastischen
maßnahmen wieder zurücknehmen könnte und
deshalb werfen ihm kritiker jetzt vor
dass sie möglicherweise die wirtschaft
amerikas und auch seine wiederwahl
wichtiger sind als die gesundheit der
bevölkerung sagt el mati wir sonst hätte
er vor schenkten herzlichen dank dafür
ja und dann gibt es noch diese frage was
ist eigentlich mit olympia in japan das
ioc und sein präsident thomas bach
spielen da auf zeit gestehen sich selbst
ein vierwöchige bedenkzeit zu und wollen
dann entscheiden die reaktionen fast
durchweg verwundert bis vernichtend von
hinhaltetaktik und führungsversagen ist
die rede
kanada schafft fakten teilt mit an den
spielen in tokio nicht teilzunehmen und
auch der deutsche olympische sportbund
sagte olympia zum geplanten zeitpunkt
geht nicht peter leise bilder wie die
der fröhlichen kanadier bei den letzten
spielen in rio hätte man sich nur schwer
vorstellen können es wird ende juli kein
fröhliches fest mehr werden
premier hat seine zuversicht nun auch
fallen lassen zieht eine verschiebung
offiziellen
die japaner müssen einen gesichtsverlust
nun nicht mehr fürchten corona ist ein
problem der gesamten welt geworden
das unheimliche virus in seiner dynamik
unterschätzt haben viele auch ioc chef
thomas bach noch vor wochen bildete er
mit premier eine festung gegen alle
zweifler
schließlich steht viel geld auf dem
spiel die vierwöchige bedenkzeit gestern
ausgesprochen dürfte kaum zu halten sein
dagmar freitag die vorsitzende des
bundestags sportausschusses kritisiert
diese hinhaltetaktik des ioc produziert
einen massiven vertrauensverlust und
zeigt auch ein eklatantes
führungsversagen liebe die frage wenn
verschieben wohin in den herbst dann
wäre das virus womöglich noch virulent
und die konkurrenz von anderen tv sport
groß in den sommer 20 21 dann wäre das
olympische dorf bereits vermietet und
weltmeisterschaften den kernsportarten
müssten teilweise weichen erst in zwei
jahren also olympia im winter und im
sommer dann so nah beieinander wie seit
30 jahren nicht mehr
dann hätte seine organisation
gravierenden umsatzeinbußen zu
befürchten das olympische feuer ist
schon da von fukushima aus wollen sie es
am donnerstag unbeirrt auf die reise
schicken noch viele fragen also auch im
sport zur corona krise gibt es auch
heute ein zdf spezial direkt nach uns
alles alltag alles anders und jederzeit
informiert bleiben sie auch heute mit
unserem live blog online auf heute de
und in der heute und auch das ist heute
noch wichtig rund einen monat ist es her
da hatten die usa und die militant
islamistischen taliban ein
friedensabkommen für afghanistan
unterzeichnet der prozess ist allerdings
ins stocken geraten auch weil es immer
noch streit gibt wer die afghanische
präsidentschaftswahl im vergangenen jahr
gewonnen hat um zu vermitteln hieß es
außenminister mike kompon überraschend
nach kabul gereist
ob es ihm gelungen ist die kontrahenten
um die macht zu einem kompromiss zu
bewegen sagte pompeo nach den gesprächen
nicht
und noch zu zwei beschlüssen des
bundeskabinetts heute zum einen geht es
wichtig in diesen zeiten um die
digitalisierung wohnungseigentümer
sollen einen glasfaseranschluss mit
hoher kapazität verlangen dürfen
die kosten müssen sie allerdings selbst
tragen zum anderen sollen mieter und
eigentümer in eigentums gemeinschaften
einen rechtlichen anspruch darauf
bekommen dass sie eine ladestation für
elektroautos einbauen können auch das
auf eigene kosten
das wetter bleibt kühl aber sehr sonnig
auch der blick aus dem fenster kann die
laune heben mehr gleich von katja hall
war das war die hauptausgabe der heute
nachrichten an einem tag an dem der
uno-generalsekretär weltweit zu einem
sofortigen waffenstillstand aufgerufen
hat eine gute idee und das nicht nur in
zeiten in denen wir alle egal wo auf
diesem planeten einen gemeinsamen feind
haben ich empfehle ihnen claus kleber im
heute journal um 21.45 er hat fragen an
den bundeswirtschaftsminister
morgen sind wir wieder für sie alle da
und zwar sehr gerne für heute machen sie
sich wo immer das geht einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
und meine damen und herren mal ein
kleiner test am anfang sind wir gesund
gehören wir keiner risikogruppe an und
haben wir mitbewohner oder
mitbewohnerinnen dann haben wir
hoffentlich diesen strahlenden
sonnenschein ausgenutzt denn mit hoch
jürgen ist es zwar sehr kühl aber eben
auch sehr sonnig und wolken kann man
höchstens mit der lupe suchen hier im
südosten bayerns würde man dann finde
ich das gilt auch in der nacht ist es
meist klar aber immer noch eisigem
ostwind und so sinken die temperaturen
bis minus zehn grad im vogtland null
grad werden es an der nordsee und nach
dieser frostigen nach dauert es lange
bis dann die temperaturen wieder etwas
ansteigen und kalt bleibt es morgen auf
jeden fall am alpenrand bei 2 grad sonst
liegen die höchstwerte zwischen 4 und 8
grad und an der nordsee im emsland und
entlang des rheins geht's auf neun bis
elf grad rauf dazu strahlt die sonne bei
immer noch eisige wind aus östlichen bis
südöstlichen richtungen und ganz ähnlich
geht es dann auch in den nächsten tagen
weiter am mittwoch gibt es noch viel
sonne bei zwei bis elf grad am
donnerstag werden die wolken etwas
dichter am freitag lässt der wind nach
und deswegen steigen die temperaturen
auf neun bis 15 grad
schönen abend noch